This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Recently, I've had the great privilege of traveling abroad. I've been to Italy and Spain, Japan a couple of times, England, Scotland. So I've been pulling out my American passport a lot lately. And every time I present it to a customs official, I always get nervous. I honestly think it's meant to make you nervous. There is something inherently fraught and maybe even a little ugly about the ritual of presenting your passport.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。最近，我有幸去国外旅行。我去过意大利和西班牙、去过好几次日本、还有英国和苏格兰。所以我最近经常掏出我的美国护照。每次我把它递给海关官员时，我总是会感到紧张。老实说，我觉得它就是为了让你感到紧张而设计的。展示护照这种仪式本身就带有某种令人不安、甚至可能有点难堪的意味。
And that this little booklet you're carrying around with you, whether it says you're from the United States or Japan or Haiti, confers so much power. I can't stand the idea that your value as a person could be determined by the fact of where you were born. But the minute you're asked to show your passport, it's obvious that's how the world works. Especially when billions of people live in countries whose passports grant them little to know meaningful access to the rest of the world. While an estimated 850 million people do not even have the documents necessary to prove their nationality or legal existence, which is why we wanted to share this story from the podcast, Far From Home, by frequent 99PI contributor Scott Gurian. A while back, Scott sat down with someone who deliberately surrendered his official nationality, including his passport, and began issuing what he believed was a better form of identification.
你随身携带的这个小册子，无论上面写着你来自美国、日本还是海地，都赋予了巨大的权力。我无法忍受这样一个想法：你作为人的价值竟然可以由你的出生地来决定。但只要你被要求出示护照，世界就是这样运转的，这一点就显露无疑。特别是当数十亿人生活在这样的国家里：他们的护照无法让他们获得任何前往世界其他地方的有意义的许可。而据估计，有 8.5 亿人甚至连证明自己国籍或合法存在的证件都没有。这就是为什么我们想分享来自播客节目《远离家乡》（Far From Home）的故事，该节目由 99PI 的常驻撰稿人斯科特·古里安（Scott Gurian）制作。不久前，斯科特采访了一位刻意放弃自己官方国籍（包括护照）的人，并开始发行他认为更好的身份证明形式。
We'll let Scott take it from here. Back in October of 2024, on the eve of the presidential election, Donald Trump held a giant political rally at Madison Square Garden in New York City. And one of the warm-up speakers was his soon-to-be political advisor, Stephen Miller. In a fiery speech, Miller expressed what would soon become the throughline of the country's new anti-immigration policy. The rise of people like Stephen Miller shows that we're living in an era when nationhood and nationhood and. and national identity seem to matter more than ever. But it's kind of strange, because at the same time that fascists in America and elsewhere
我们把接下来的时间交给斯科特。早在 2024 年 10 月，即总统大选前夕，唐纳德·特朗普在纽约市麦迪逊广场花园举办了一场大型政治集会。其中一位暖场发言人是他即将上任的政治顾问斯蒂芬·米勒。米勒在慷慨激昂的演讲中，表达了很快将成为该国新反移民政策核心主旨的内容。像斯蒂芬·米勒这样的人的崛起表明，我们正生活在一个国家地位和国家身份似乎比以往任何时候都更加重要的时代。但这有点奇怪，因为与此同时，美国和其他地方的法西斯分子
are trying to get us all to think in terms of nations, we're dealing with all these global problems like pandemics, climate change, and AI. Meanwhile, technology in the 21st century often makes it easy to ignore things like nationality and national boundaries altogether. Therefore, I know this might sound sort of radical, but if it ever made,
正试图让我们所有人都以国家为单位来思考，而我们却在应对所有这些全球性问题，比如大流行病、气候变化和人工智能。与此同时，21世纪的技术往往让人很容易完全忽视国籍和国境之类的东西。因此，我知道这听起来可能有点激进，但如果它曾经成真过，
made any sense, the entire concept of the nation state can sometimes seem kind of quaint and outdated for the modern world. This is the story of one man who reached all these conclusions himself more than 75 years ago, way ahead of his time. His name was Gary Davis, and I went to interview him back in 2009 when he was 88 years old. According to my directions, Gary's house was in South Burlington, Vermont, in the United States of America, but, you know, but But as soon as I pulled into his driveway, I noticed a sign next to his front door, proclaiming it sovereign world territory. It's good to meet you. Sorry, I'm running a few minutes behind here.
曾经有过任何意义的话，那么民族国家这一整个概念，对现代世界而言有时显得有些古怪和过时。这是一个人的故事，他在 75 年前就自己得出了所有这些结论，远远超出了他的时代。他的名字叫加里·戴维斯（Gary Davis）。我在 2009 年去采访他时，他已经 88 岁了。根据我得到的路线指引，加里的房子位于美利坚合众国的佛蒙特州南伯灵顿，但是，你知道，但就在我把车驶入他的车道时，我注意到他前门旁边的牌子，上面宣称这里是主权世界领土。很高兴见到你。抱歉，我这里稍微耽误了几分钟。
He came up to me, pointed out that I was standing on planet Earth, and asked me to present my world citizen card. I didn't have one, so thankfully he decided to waive the requirement. Then he led me into his living room where we'd sit for the next five hours, talking about a choice he made when he was 26 years old. in 1948. It was a simple act that took just a minute to perform, but it would make the rest of his life really complicated. Over the next six decades, he'd be detained and imprisoned countless times, dragged off the floor of the United Nations General Assembly, and gained millions of followers,
他朝我走来，指出我正站在地球上，并要求我出示世界公民证。我没有这个证件，所以谢天谢地，他决定免除这一要求。接着，他带我进了他的客厅，我们在那里坐了整整五个小时，谈论他在 26 岁时做出的一个决定，那是在 1948 年。这是一个只需一分钟就能完成的简单举动，但它却让他的余生变得无比复杂。在接下来的六十年里，他无数次被拘留和关押，从联合国大会的会场上被强行拖走，并获得了数百万的追随者。
all while confronting bureaucrats who had absolutely no idea what to do with him. What set this chain of events into motion was Gary's decision to stand before a guy in a gray suit at the U.S. Embassy in Paris, put his hand on a Bible and read a couple of lines off a sheet of paper. I hereby swear that I desire to make a formal renunciation of my American nationality, and pursuant thereto, hereby absolutely and entirely renounce my nationality in the United States and all rights and privileges thereunto, and abjure all allegiance and fidelity to the United States of America. Gary's life journey that led him up to that point was pretty unexpected.
这一切发生的同时，他还在与那些完全不知道该拿他怎么办的官僚们对抗。这一系列事件的导火索，是加里决定站在巴黎美国大使馆一个穿灰西装的家伙面前，将手放在《圣经》上，宣读纸上的一两行字。我在此宣誓，我希望正式放弃我的美国国籍，并因此绝对且彻底放弃我在美国的国籍以及与之相关的一切权利和特权，并放弃对美利坚合众国的一切忠诚和效忠。导致加里走到这一步的人生旅程是相当出人意料的。
You see, growing up in the 1930s and 40s, he had a lot going for him. He was born into privilege to a wealthy Philadelphia family whose car was a chauffeur at Rolls-Royce. His father, Meyer Davis, was a famous bandleader at the time. This is his orchestra you're hearing right now. Family friends included Ethel Merman and Bob Hope. As the young man, Gary was a rising Broadway star who once performed as an understudy to the famous actor Danny Kay. Then came World War II.
你看，在 20 世纪 30 和 40 年代成长期间，他可谓占尽天时地利。他出生于费城的一个富裕家庭，家境优越，他们的座驾是劳斯莱斯专车司机。他的父亲迈尔·戴维斯（Meyer Davis）当时是一位著名的乐队领队。你现在听到的就是他的管弦乐队。他的家庭朋友包括埃瑟·默曼（Ethel Merman）和鲍勃·霍普（Bob Hope）。作为一个年轻人，加里是百老汇冉冉升起的新星，曾担任著名演员丹尼·凯（Danny Kaye）的候补演员。然后第二次世界大战爆发了。
Gary was drafted into the Army Air Corps and trained to pilot a B-17 bomber. The experience had a profound impact on him. That was a whole reassessment of my role in life. How dared they put me in this role? How humiliating to my soul, my moral character, my profession. Everything you learn in kindergarten is being thrust aside and now you're a killer in the name of the nation. But you're not prepared for that. You're not prepared to even think about that. There's no education for that. At least it wasn't for me.
加里被征召加入陆军航空兵，并接受了驾驶 B-17 轰炸机的训练。这段经历对他的影响深远。那是对我在生活中的角色的一次彻底重新评估。他们怎么敢把我放在这个角色里？这对我灵魂、我的道德品质、我的职业是多么大的侮辱。你在幼儿园学到的一切都被抛在一边，现在你成了以国家名义杀人的杀手。但你对此毫无准备。你甚至没有准备好去思考这个问题。根本没有这方面的教育。至少对我来说是没有的。
Flying bombing raids over Brandenburg and losing his older brother Bud to a German torpedo caused him to reevaluate not just his participation in the war, but his identity as an American citizen. I said there is something intrinsically wrong with society, and I'm not going to play this game anymore. So that started me on a whole wave of thinking about how not to play the game without going to a desert island, you know, and canceling out. He started reading about philosophy and history and studying the law. Eventually, he concluded that the only way to prevent future wars was for people to remove themselves from the system that creates the us versus them mentality. So after a year of planning and strategizing, Gary decided to act. I walked into the U.S. Embassy on May 25th, 1948, and I asked to renounce my nationality.
在勃兰登堡上空执行轰炸任务，以及哥哥巴德（Bud）死于德国鱼雷，使他不仅重新评估了自己对战争的参与，还重新评估了自己作为美国公民的身份。我说，社会本身存在根本性的错误，我再也不想玩这个游戏了。于是这引发了我的一系列思考：如何在不退居荒岛且不与世隔绝的情况下，做到不参与这个游戏。他开始阅读哲学和历史并研究法律。最终，他得出结论，防止未来战争的唯一方法是让人类脱离那种制造“我们对他们”心态的系统。因此，经过一年的规划和筹备，加里决定付诸行动。我在 1948 年 5 月 25 日走进了美国大使馆，要求放弃我的国籍。
Well, everybody was appalled, of course. We're here to protect you. You know, I said, no, you can't protect me. You know, you didn't protect my brother. And you didn't protect anybody outside that I killed and so forth. So finally, I convinced them. The U.S. State Department says just a few thousand Americans a year give up their citizens. So Gary's action was kind of unusual to begin with. What made it even stranger was that he wasn't becoming a citizen of any other country.
当然，所有人都惊呆了。我们是来保护你的。你知道，我说，不，你们保护不了我。你知道，你们没有保护我的哥哥。你们也没有保护我在外面杀掉的任何人等等。所以最后，我说服了他们。美国国务院表示，每年只有几千名美国人放弃公民身份。因此加里的举动一开始就有点不同寻常。更奇怪的是，他并没有加入任何其他国家的国籍。
They said, okay, Mr. Davis, now you're a stateless person. And you have something that belongs to us. I said, what was that? The United States passport, please give it to us. So then the fun began. Gary left the embassy and went to the local office of the Associated Press to tell his story to the world. Then he went back to his hotel room to try to get some. some rest, but word had gotten out, so the phone began ringing constantly. First, it was United
他们说，好吧，戴维斯先生，现在你是个无国籍人士了。你手里有属于我们的东西。我说，那是什么？美国护照，请交给我们。于是好戏开场了。加里离开大使馆，来到美联社当地办公室，向世界讲述他的故事。然后他回到酒店房间试图休息一下，但消息已经传开了，电话开始响个不停。首先是合众社，
Press, then Reuters, then the International News Service, all asking him for interviews. As I sat in Gary's living room listening to his stories, I asked him to show me his scrapbook of press clippings from the days that followed. These are U.S. stories. The Lordafia News, May 27, 1948. This went all over the press. What is this headline here? Say, young citizen of nowhere must live there, too. See, the journalists had a lot of fun with me. I mean, here was a big story. It was unique.
然后是路透社，接着是国际新闻社，都要求采访他。当我坐在加里的客厅里听他讲这些故事时，我请他给我看他珍藏的剪贴报，里面记录了接下来的日子的剪报。这些都是美国的报道。《洛德菲亚新闻》，1948 年 5 月 27 日。这篇报道登上了各大媒体。这里的头条是什么？上面写着，无国籍的年轻公民也必须在那里生活。你看，记者们拿我开玩笑。我的意思是，这是一个大新闻。它是独一无二的。
It was personal. It was political. It was active. The guy was on the line himself. It wasn't just a theory. Did people see it as a publicity stunt? The publicity stunt didn't come into play simply because of the renunciation. This guy's giving up United States citizenship.
它是个人的。它是政治的。它是积极的。当事人亲自上阵了。这不仅仅是一个理论。人们把它看作是一场公关特技吗？公关特技并不是因为放弃国籍而产生的。这家伙居然放弃了美国公民身份，
that's not a publicity stunt. It threw in a counterlight the so-called theory that everybody wanted to be a United States citizen. Everybody was trying to get into the United States after the war. Here's a guy who gives up his United States citizenship. What is he? Is a crackpot? Is he a clown? What's his motivation?
这可不是什么公关特技。它以一种对立的光芒打破了所谓“每个人都想成为美国公民”的理论。战后每个人都试图进入美国。这里却有一个人放弃了他的美国国籍。他是什么人？是个怪人？是个小丑？他的动机是什么？
In other words, we want to find out more of who he is and what his real reasons are. Gary attempted to answer some of these questions by releasing a statement explaining his action. In the absence of an international government, our world politically is now a naked anarchy. Two global wars have shown that as long as two or more powerful, sovereign nation states regard their own national law supreme and sufficient to handle affairs between nations, there can be no order on a planetary level. This international anarchy is moving swiftly toward a final war. I no longer find it compatible with my inner convictions to contribute to this anarchy,
换句话说，我们想更多地了解他是谁以及他真正的动机是什么。加里试图通过发表一份解释其行为的声明来回答其中一些问题。在没有国际政府的情况下，我们在政治上的世界现在是一个赤裸裸的无政府状态。两次全球大战表明，只要两个或更多强大的主权民族国家仍然视其自身的国家法律为至高无上、足以处理国家间事务，那么在星球层面上就不可能有秩序可言。这种国际上的无政府状态正迅速走向终极战争。我不再发现这符合我内心的信念，去助长这种无政府状态，
and thus be a party to the inevitable annihilation of our civilization by remaining solely loyal to one of these sovereign nation states. I should like to consider myself a citizen of the world. To be clear, this wasn't an entirely new or original concept. Many notable individuals throughout history, including Socrates, Charlie Chaplin, and more recently Barack Obama have called themselves world citizens, but Gary took this idea to another level. For the rest of his life, he'd be a free agent operating by his own set of rules and without any sort of roadmap or instruction manual.
从而通过仅忠于这些主权民族国家之一，成为导致我们文明不可避免毁灭的同谋。我想把自己视为世界公民。需要澄清的是，这并不是一个全新或原创的概念。历史上许多杰出人物，包括苏格拉底、查理·卓别林，以及最近的贝拉克·奥巴马，都曾自称世界公民，但加里将这个想法推向了另一个高度。在余下的生命中，他将成为一个自由人，按照自己的一套规则行事，没有任何路线图或操作手册。
Being neutral, my position was outside the framework of the laws of the nations. It was very exciting, you know, wondering what's going to happen now, what's the French government going to say? The answer came quickly. Given that he was now undocumented, French officials gave him a deadline to get out. But without a passport, where could he go? Traveling anywhere was sure to be difficult. But just as Gary was considering his options, he had a stroke of luck.
保持中立，我的立场在国家法律框架之外。这非常令人兴奋，你知道，想知道接下来会发生什么，法国政府会怎么说？答案很快就来了。鉴于他现在没有证件，法国官员给他设定了离境期限。但没有护照，他能去哪里？去任何地方肯定都困难重重。但正当加里在权衡选择时，他交了好运。
The day that I was supposed to be out of France was September 11, 1948. That was the day that the General Assembly of the United Nations took over a little part of Paris. at the Trocadero, and it was declared international territory. It was the only place I could go, actually, without going to jail or without going to another nation and facing the same problem that I faced in France. So I went to the United Nations. I made a press statement saying, I'm your first citizen, you know, I have to live here. Gary and some friends camped out on the front steps, calling for world citizenship as a path to lasting peace,
我本该离开法国的日子是 1948 年 9 月 11 日。那一天，联合国大会接管了特罗卡德罗（Trocadero）的一小部分巴黎领土，并宣布其为国际领土。实际上，这是我唯一能去的地方，既不用坐牢，也不用去另一个国家并面临我在法国遇到过的同样的问题。所以我去了联合国。我发表了一份新闻声明，说我是你们的第一公民，你知道，我必须住在这里。加里和一些朋友露营在前台台阶上，呼吁将世界公民身份作为通往持久和平的途径，
something the UN's predecessor, League of Nations, had failed to uphold. Officials didn't know quite what to do with them. Then that November, Gary managed to gain access to one of the General Assembly's meetings, and he used the opportunity to draw attention to his cause. An incident that reflects the mood of an impatient world interrupts proceedings at the United Nations Assembly. All the press was there, and we had huge lights, and we had the balcony box wired up so that it could take our speech. All the delegates were on the floor. Eleanor Roosevelt, you know, with their headphones,
这是联合国的上一任机构国际联盟未能维护的东西。官员们不知道该拿他们怎么办。接着在那年 11 月，加里设法进入了联合国大会的一次会议，并利用这个机会引起人们对他的事业的关注。一个反映不耐烦世界情绪的事件打断了联合国大会的议程。所有的媒体都在那里，我们有巨大的灯光，我们把阳台包厢接上了线，以便可以录下我们的演讲。所有的代表都在大厅里。埃莉诺·罗斯福，你知道，戴着耳机，
they were wondering where this voice is coming from. Mr. Bershinsky looks on as the interrupter, Gary Davis, self-styled first citizen of the world, is hustled out. Speak to the people, shall I speak? Can you let me? I said, I interrupted the name of people, not represented here. The nations you represent, divide us, separate us,
他们想知道这个声音是从哪里来的。别尔申斯基先生看着打断会议的加里·戴维斯（自封的世界第一公民）被匆忙带出去。对人民说话，我该说吗？你能让我说吗？我说，我是以不在这里代表的人民的名义打断的。你们代表的国家分裂了我们，隔离了我们，
and lead us to the Biss of World War III. What we need is one government for one world. And if you don't do it, step aside. We're going to do it ourselves. We had screaming headlines the next day. Those headlines were seen by people around the world. Authors and intellectuals like Richard Wright, Albert Camus, and even Albert Einstein spoke out on Davis's behalf,
并将我们引向第三次世界大战的深渊。我们需要一个世界一个政府。如果你不这么做，就请让开。我们要自己来。第二天我们上了轰动一时的头条新闻。世界各地的人们都看到了这些头条新闻。理查德·赖特、阿尔贝·加缪甚至阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦等作家和知识分子都为戴维斯发声，
and he began receiving letters from supporters near and far. Remember, the war had just recently ended, and memories of the Nazi occupation and the Holocaust were still fresh in people's minds, especially there in Europe, so folks were eager to hear what Gary had to say. Less than two weeks after his storming of the UN, he gave a speech in a Paris auditorium, and 20,000 people showed up. Many of them expressed interest in his movement, so he got to work creating something they could actually join.
他开始收到来自四面八方的支持者的信件。记住，战争才刚刚结束不久，纳粹占领和犹太人大屠杀的记忆在人们心中依然鲜活，特别是在欧洲，所以人们渴望听到加里的话。在他冲击联合国不到两周后，他在巴黎的一个礼堂发表了演讲，有 2,0000 人到场。其中许多人对他的运动表现出兴趣，于是他开始着手创建他们可以真正加入的东西。
We set up a registry of world citizens. We hired a hall, and we started issuing a world citizen card. And that was the first thing. We were IDing a whole new constituency, a world constituency. It was a new language. Though Gary Davis no longer had a nationality, he still considered New York his home. So he returned to the U.S. Embassy and managed to convince authorities to let him migrate back to his native land. After arriving, he got married, had a kid, went back to acting, and tried returning to his pre-war life.
我们建立了一个世界公民登记处。我们租了一个大厅，开始发放世界公民证。这是第一步。我们在识别一个全新选区，即世界选区。这是一种新的语言。尽管加里·戴维斯不再有国籍，但他仍然认为纽约是他的家。因此，他回到了美国大使馆，并设法说服当局让他返回祖国。抵达后，他结了婚，生了孩子，重返演艺界，试图回到他战前的生活。
But his heart just wasn't into it. I was making good money in show business, and I had so many offers, and I gave it all up. I left the top show in Broadway after three days of rehearsal. And I told the producer, I'm sorry, Harris, I can't be in this show because I got to work for world peace. Unsure of what to do next, he struggled with how to navigate life as a stateless individual. So I went to the top civil rights lawyer in New York. I told him, I said, I'm not a citizen here. I'm not an immigre.
但他实在是心有余力不足。我在演艺界赚了不少钱，我接到了很多邀约，但我把这一切都放弃了。在排练了三天后，我离开了百老汇的一流演出。我告诉制片人，我很抱歉，哈里斯，我不能演这个节目，因为我必须为世界和平工作。由于不知接下来该做什么，他努力摸索着如何以无国籍个人的身份在生活中前行。所以我去找了纽约顶级的民权律师。我告诉他，我说，我不是这里的公民。我不是移民。
I'm not a visitor. What is my status? And they had a full staff meeting on that. And they said, you're not really here. Legally, you're not here. Physically, you're here. And the government has recognized you physically. Therefore, not being within the framework of the United States law,
我不是访客。我的身份是什么？他们为此开了一个全体员工会议。他们说，你实际上并不在这里。从法律上讲，你并不在这里。从物理上讲，你在这里。政府在物理上承认了你。因此，不属于美国法律的框架之内，
you have been recognized by the United States government as a sovereign, like the Iroquois Indians. So you've got nationhood within you. You call yourself a word. world citizen and you have all these people out there as world citizens, how can you be a citizen without a government? They said, you've got to declare your government. Once you declare the world government, then you can do a lot of things. First of all, you can issue your own documents, your own money, you can declare war on the United States, and then the United States will beat you,
你已被美国政府承认为主权者，就像易洛魁印第安人一样。所以你的体内拥有国籍。你自称为世界公民，你外面有这么多的世界公民，没有政府你怎么能成为公民呢？他们说，你必须宣告你的政府。一旦你宣告了世界政府，你就可以做很多事情。首先，你可以发行你自己的文件，你自己的货币，你可以向美国宣战，然后美国会打败你，
and then it has to take care of you for the rest of your life. They had a field date. You know, these were lawyers kind of having fun. This was a new problem. which they never had. Gary gave this some thought and decided to follow their advice. On September 4, 1953, he formalized that registry of supporters he had created while he was in Paris and founded the world government of world citizens. He opened an office in New York and hired some staff and interns to carry out the day-to-day running of the government via a non-profit organization called the World Service Authority.
然后它就必须照顾你余下的生。他们大开眼界。你知道，这些律师有点在开玩笑。这是一个他们从未见过的新问题。加里对此进行了思考，并决定听从他们的建议。1953 年 9 月 4 日，他将他在巴黎期间创建的支持者登记处正式化，并成立了世界公民世界政府。他在纽约开设了一个办公室，并聘请了一些员工和实习生，通过一个名为世界服务机构（World Service Authority）的非营利组织来负责政府的日常运转。
And they started issuing documents, including birth and marriage certificates, international residence permits, and political asylum cards for people who contacted them requesting help. So at this point, I had to ask Gary the question that's probably on your mind right now, which is some variation of, can they do that? I mean, here you have this guy who decided he wants to form a new government that anyone can join, and he's printing official-looking credentials for people to present to border guards and bureaucrats. Were these documents actually legitimate? Well, is the United States legitimate? Is war legitimate?
他们开始签发证件，包括出生证明和结婚证书、国际居留许可，以及为联系他们寻求帮助的人发放政治庇护卡。所以在这个时候，我不得不问加里那个你现在可能也想问的问题，那就是各种形式的“他们能这么做吗？”我的意思是，这里有这样一个人，他决定想要成立一个任何人都可以加入的新政府，而且他在打印看起来很官方的凭证，供人们向边防警卫和官僚出示。这些文件真的合法吗？那么，美国合法吗？战争合法吗？
You know, turn it around, a question around. Who is to say what is legitimate? Is not my claiming to be who I am legitimate? If you're in a desert island alone, are you legitimate? You're the government, you're the citizenry, you're alone, do whatever you want. But you see me coming all along in a raft and you say, well, we're together now, we form a community. Then we legitimize the community.
你知道，反过来问一个问题。谁来决定什么是合法的？我声称我是谁难道不合法吗？如果你独自在一个荒岛上，你合法吗？你是政府，你是公民，你孤身一人，你想做什么就做什么。但你看到我一路乘着木筏驶来，你说，嗯，我们现在在一起了，我们组成了一个社区。然后我们使社区合法化。
How do government start in the first place? They don't start with governors. Governments started by people deciding to have a government, to legitimize themselves within a community. But enough with the philosophizing. From a legal perspective, Gary told me that, yes. He said the work of his new world government was entirely legitimate because it was based on the articles of the Universal Declaration of Human Rights, a UN document describing the rights and freedoms of all people.
政府最初是怎么开始的？它们不是由统治者开始的。政府是由人们决定拥有一个政府、在社区内使自己合法化而开始的。但抛开这些哲学思辨不谈。从法律角度来看，加里告诉我，是的。他说他新世界政府的工作完全合法，因为它是基于《世界人权宣言》的条款，这是一份描述所有人权利和自由的联合国文件。
Now, the first article that we've taken is the Article 13. Section 2, which is an article on freedom of travel, which says everyone has the right to leave any country, including his own, and to return to his country. But what is a country? Tom Payne said, my country is the world. And when you think that you can get around the world in two days today, you can say, well, really, the world is a country at this point. So we need a document based upon freedom of travel. Hence, the creation of the world passport printed in seven languages, including the made-up universal language of Esperanto. So it's made to look like any other passport typically issued by a nation state that someone would have?
我们采纳的第一条是第 13 条。第 2 款，这是一条关于旅行自由的条款，规定每个人都有权离开任何国家，包括他自己的国家，并返回他的国家。但什么是国家？托马斯·潘恩说，我的国家是世界。当你想到今天你可以在两天内环游世界时，你可以说，嗯，实际上，在这一点上，世界就是一个国家。所以我们需要一份基于旅行自由的文件。因此，世界护照诞生了，它用七种语言印刷，包括人造世界语。所以它看起来就像民族国家通常签发的任何人都会有的护照吗？
Yeah, yeah. It's a document which they can look at and it IDs you completely. But it's just not a national passport. This is all important for the guy on the frontier because this is the way they operate. You see, it's for him. It's not for us. We don't believe in passports. We think they're stupid. In fact, many times I say, look, our passport is a joke. It's a joke on whereas your passport, your national passport's a joke on you. Gary said he thinks the whole process of making someone get a stamp and a little book in order to cross an imaginary border is really dumb. But by creating his own passport, he was basically thumbing his nose at the establishment and saying, see, I could play this game too. Now, in case you're thinking that Gary just started the world government as a form of political feeder, I should explain that he saw his organization as serving a really,
对，对。这是一份他们可以查看并完全识别你身份的文件。但这不仅仅是国家护照。这对边境上的人来说非常重要，因为这就是他们的运作方式。你看，这是为他准备的。不是为我们准备的。我们不相信护照。我们觉得它们很愚蠢。事实上，我经常说，看，我们的护照是个笑话。而你的护照，你的国家护照是对你的一个笑话。加里说，他认为为了跨越一个想象中的边界而强迫某人获得盖章和小册子的整个过程真的很蠢。但通过制作他自己的护照，他基本上是对建制派嗤之以鼻，并说，看，我也能玩这个游戏。现在，如果你认为加里创办世界政府只是一种政治噱头，我应该解释一下，他认为他的组织是在满足一个非常真实的需求。
real need. You see, many of the letters he and his colleagues received, especially in those early days, came from refugees who were stateless themselves, but unlike Gary, they didn't choose to end up that way. They needed a document to say who they were. They couldn't get it from the nation. There are huge refugee camps outside of Djibouti or in the Sudan and so forth, and the people or families living under tents in the heat. Now, the United Nations is not issuing them documents, but the World Service Authority is. And believe it or not, these passports and other documents that Gary and his team of rag-tag visionaries created actually worked some of the time.
你看，他和他的同事收到的许多信件，特别是在早期，来自无国籍的难民，但与加里不同的是，他们并不是自己选择走到这一步的。他们需要一份文件来证明他们是谁。他们无法从国家那里获得。吉布提或苏丹等地外面有巨大的难民营，人们或家庭在炎热中住在帐篷里。现在，联合国没有给他们发证件，但世界服务机构发了。信不信由你，加里和他的乌合之众远见者团队制作的这些护照和其他文件在某些时候确实起作用了。
Gary told me the story, for example, about the time members of the Ogoni tribe from southern Nigeria reached out asking for help. After protesting the Shell Oil Company's environmental destruction of their land, they had to flee across the border to a refugee camp in the neighboring country of Benin. They didn't have any identity documents, though, so the world government made passports for close to 2,000 of them, which they were then able to use to obtain visas to get out. There was also the young conscientious objector who successfully avoided registering for the draft through some clever letter writing, claiming that his citizenship in the world government forbade
例如，加里给我讲了一个故事，讲述了来自尼日利亚南部的奥戈尼（Ogoni）部落的成员伸出援手寻求帮助的时候。在抗议壳牌石油公司对他们土地的环境破坏后，他们不得不逃越边境，来到邻国贝宁的一个难民营。然而，他们没有任何身份证件，因此世界政府为近 2,000 人制作了护照，他们随后能够使用这些护照获得签证以离开。还有一个年轻的兵役反对者，通过一些聪明的信件成功避开兵役登记，声称他在世界政府中的公民身份禁止
him from joining the American military, and the woman in Uganda caught in a bind when her country's dictator decided to expel her and other members of the country's Indian minority. We received a urgent telegram saying that one of the mothers, the Indian mothers, had given birth at Uganda airport. So what the baby needed was an immediate birth certificate because they were going to be picked up the next day by a British plane. And I got on the top rider and wrote out the first world birth certificate and went to a stationary store and put a seal on it and so forth. And I got it in the mail at 5 o'clock and got down to that airport the next day. And the plane came in. The captain of the plane said, where's the baby's documents?
他加入美国军队，还有一个乌干达妇女陷入困境，当时该国的独裁者决定驱逐她和该国印度少数民族的其他成员。我们收到了一份紧急电报，说其中一位母亲，一位印度母亲，在乌干达机场生下了一个孩子。所以这个婴儿需要一张即时的出生证明，因为他们第二天将被一架英国飞机接走。我上了顶楼，写下了第一张世界出生证明，去文具店盖上印章等等。我在 5 点钟把信寄了出去，第二天赶到了那个机场。飞机进来了。机长说，孩子的证件在哪里？
We can't take anybody without documents. And the mother handed him the document that I had just typed out on my typewriter. Well, the baby was in the mother's arms, of course. So the captain accepted that. He had to accept that. And a plane flew to Heathrow. And that was the document upon which that baby got into UK with the mother. In the decades that followed, the world government has continued its work, issuing more than 5 million legal documents, including nearly 1 million passports.
没有证件我们不能带任何人。母亲把刚刚我在打字机上打出的文件递给了他。好吧，婴儿当然是在母亲的怀里。所以机长接受了。他不得不接受。飞机飞往了希思罗机场。这就是那个婴儿带着母亲进入英国的文件。在随后的几十年里，世界政府继续其工作，发行了超过 500 万份法律文件，其中包括近 100 万本护照。
They say that Ecuador and five African countries have offered official recognition at one point or another. and according to copies of passport stamps and visas people have sent them, nearly every other country in the world has also accepted these passports for travel on at least a few occasions. While some of these might be instances where the border guards simply weren't paying close attention to the pieces of paper in front of them, the world government contends that the fact that their passports have been honored thousands of times over the years is proof that these can't just all be mistakes.
他们说，厄瓜多尔和五个非洲国家曾在某个时候提供过官方承认，根据人们寄给他们的护照盖章和签证复印件，世界上几乎其他所有国家也至少在几次场合接受了这些护照用于旅行。虽然其中一些可能属于边防警卫根本没有密切关注面前纸张的情况，但世界政府认为，他们的护照多年来被尊重了数千次，这证明这些不可能全部都是错误。
But I'd be remiss if I didn't mention that for every instance where people have had success using these documents, there are many other times when they haven't worked as intended. Some critics have charged over the years that the world government is in the business of selling false hope to undocumented individuals, given that the legal recognition and acceptance of world passports and ID cards is unpredictable and by no means guaranteed. An organization spokesman said, however, that simply providing people with papers
但我若是不提，那就是我的疏忽了：每一次人们成功使用这些文件的背后，都有许多其他时候它们没有按预期发挥作用。多年来，一些批评人士指责世界政府一直在向无证件个人兜售虚假希望，鉴于世界护照和身份证件的法律承认和接受是不可预测的，绝无保证。然而，该组织发言人表示，仅仅为人们提供纸张
gives them some degree of human dignity. Gary, for his part, had little sympathy for anyone who said his documents like the World Passport were a little more than novelty items. Does it work? You know, I have to say to you, no, it doesn't work. It doesn't work.
就能赋予他们一定程度的人格尊严。加里本人对任何说他的文件（如世界护照）不过是新奇玩艺儿的人，并没有什么同理心。它管用吗？你知道，我不得不对你说，不，它不管用。它不管用。
I work. I'm the citizen. The documents do nothing. It's a tool. A hammer does nothing unless you pick it up. and know how to use it. My consciousness works, and I'm conscious of who I am,
我管用。我是公民。文件什么也做不了。它只是一个工具。除非你把它拿起来，
that's the only thing that works. We say that to everybody who calls us. We're not doing anything, really, except giving testament to who you are. In other words, he said, people can't simply present a world passport at a national border and expect to breeze through immigration
并且知道如何使用它，否则锤子什么也做不了。我的意识管用，我意识到我是谁，那是唯一管用的东西。我们对每个打电话给我们的人都这么说。我们其实什么也没做，只是证明了你是谁。换句话说，他说，人们不能简单地在国家边界出示世界护照，并指望像使用国家护照那样轻松通过移民局。
the way they might with a national passport. They need to stand up for their rights and know the right things to say to convince the Border Guard to let them through. Did you claim to be a world citizen? Do you know anything about the Declaration of Human Rights? Have you read any of my books? You know, you're on that front line.
他们需要捍卫自己的权利，并知道该说哪些正确的话来劝说边防警卫放行。你声称自己是世界公民吗？你对《人权宣言》了解多少？你读过我的书吗？你知道，你就在前线。
You're the guy who gets out there and talks to these idiot officials. If you ever learn how to talk back to them, then they're going to put you down. They're going to humiliate you every time. Then you're going to write to me or call me and say, I paid for that passport, and it doesn't work. When people say your passport,
你就是那个走出去和这些白痴官员交谈的人。如果你学会了如何顶撞他们，那么他们就会压制你。他们每次都会羞辱你。然后你会写信给我或打电话给我，说我为那本护照付了钱，但它不管用。当人们说你的护照
doesn't work. You say, well, I went to India with a first passport number 0,000,001. And I left India, three months later, with 17 visas on my first passport. Don't tell me that passport doesn't work. But even Gary, who was well-versed in international law and had all the best legal arguments at his disposal had mixed success. Over the years, by his own account, he was imprisoned 34 times in nine different countries for trying to exercise what he saw as his right to freedom of travel as a world citizen.
不管用时。你会说，嗯，我带着第一本编号为 0,000,001 的世界护照去了印度。三个月后，我带着盖有 17 个签证的第一本护照离开了印度。别告诉我那本护照不管用。但即使是精通国际法律、手头拥有所有最佳法律论据的加里，也并非总能一帆风顺。多年来，据他自己统计，他因试图行使他作为世界公民的旅行自由权，曾在 9 个不同的国家被监禁了 34 次。
Sometimes it was because his passport was outright rejected. Other times, he was initially allowed to enter a country, but then later arrested. Since he disagreed with the concept of nation states, there were also instances where he crossed the border by riding a bicycle on a path through the woods
有时是因为他的护照被断然拒绝。其他时候，他最初被允许进入一个国家，但后来被捕。由于他不同意民族国家的概念，有时他甚至通过骑自行车穿过树林中的小路越境，
instead of going through an official crossing, so he'd get in trouble for that. When I first learned about Gary Davis a number of years ago, I was intrigued. So I actually sent away for one of his world passports, but it's been sitting in a drawer ever since, and I've never tried using it myself, because I'll be honest. While I really appreciate the concept of a world without borders, I'm not an activist for the cause. I mean, it's not something that I feel so strongly about that I'd be willing to risk being detained for hours or even days in some foreign country's airport and missing my flight. light. When I'm traveling, I usually just want to get to my final destination without engaging in
而不是通过官方口岸，因此他会因此惹上麻烦。多年前我第一次了解到加里·戴维斯时，我很感兴趣。所以我甚至申请了一本他的世界护照，但它从那以后一直放在抽我自己从未尝试使用过它，因为说实话。虽然我真的很欣赏一个没有边界的世界的概念，但我不是这项事业的积极分子。我的意思是，这并不是那种让我愿意冒着在某个外国机场被拘留数小时甚至数天并错过航班的风险去强烈支持的事情。飞行。当我旅行时，我通常只想到达最终目的地，而不想一路上与边防警卫进行政治和哲学辩论。
political and philosophical arguments with border guards along the way. I mentioned to Gary that I had one of his passports but never used it, and he called me a coward. I understand why he sees it that way, because for him, this was a cause worth devoting his life to. I've taken my case up to the Supreme Court. They didn't hear the case, but when the Supreme Court denies your writ, that means the lower court decisions prevail. But all the lower court decisions were that I was an excludable alien, but they couldn't exclude me. There's nowhere they could send you, too. There's no where they could send me. So Gary was basically in a stalemate with the U.S. government, living out his life in his humble home there in South Burlington, Vermont, despite existing in a sort of legal limbo.
我向加里提到我有他的护照但从未使用过，他称我为懦夫。我理解他为什么会这么看，因为对他来说，这是一项值得为之奉献一生事业。我把我的案子打到了最高法院。他们没有审理这个案子，但当最高法院驳回你的令状时，这意味着下级法院的判决占上风。但所有下级法院的判决都是我是可驱逐的外国人，但他们无法驱逐我。他们无处可遣返你。他们无处可遣返我。所以加里基本上与美国政府陷入了僵局，尽管生活在某种法律灰色地带，却在佛蒙特州南伯灵顿他简陋的家中度过余生。
One journalist went to the immigration department. She asked, what is Gary Davis' status? And his answer was, Gary Davis is a legal fiction. That means I don't exist. If that's not proof of the power of an individual, that according to the United States, according to all the nation states, you claim to be a world citizen, you become a legal fiction that they can't deal with you. But you're still existent. In addition to issuing passports, birth certificates, and ID cards, Gary's world government has created a legal department to provide support for document holders whose paperwork is denied. They've established a sovereign order of world guards that anyone can join, and they've even printed their own stamps and world money.
一名记者去了移民部门。她问，加里·戴维斯的身份是什么？他的回答是，加里·戴维斯是一个法律虚构。这意味着我并不存在。如果这还不是个人力量的证明，根据美国、根据所有民族国家，你声称自己是世界公民，你就会变成一个他们无法处理的法律虚构。但你依然存在。除了发行护照、出生证明和身份证件之外，加里的世界政府还建立了一个法律部门，为证件被拒绝的持有人提供支持。他们建立了一个任何人都可以加入的世界卫士主权秩序，甚至印刷了他们自己的邮票和世界货币。
This is our world treasury here. He pulled out a box. As a world citizen, I decided that we need a new currency. The currency is called the Mondo, M-O-N-D-O. And this money is based upon energy. Where is the greatest source of energy? It's the sun, obviously. Buckminster Fuller says,
这是我们的世界国库。他拿出一个盒子。作为一名世界公民，我决定我们需要一种新货币。这种货币叫曼多（Mondo），即 M-O-N-D-O。这种货币基于能量。能量的最大来源是什么？很明显，是太阳。巴克明斯特·富勒（Buckminster Fuller）说，
There's more energy poured on the earth by the sun in five minutes than humanity uses all year. These are kilowatt dollars. This is a peace currency. You can't fight wars with it. So look at the immediate trust that it'll have. I get a lot of letters for people to donate money. I always put this money in, and I explain it with a sheet. This is world money.
太阳在五分钟内倾泻到地球上的能量比人类一年使用的还要多。这些是千瓦美元。这是一种和平货币。你无法用它打仗。所以看看它将具有的即时信任度。我收到很多人们捐款的信件。我总是把这些钱放进去，并附上一张纸解释。这是世界货币。
You want donations from a world citizen? This is what you're going to get. Now, I haven't gone into the markets. and started using it at this point, but that'll come. Gary passed away in 2013 at the age of 91, and he was active until the end. Shortly before his death, he mailed a world government passport to WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange when he was holed up in the Ecuadorian embassy in London, and also to fugitive national security contractor Edward Snowden,
你想从世界公民那里得到捐款吗？这就是你将得到的。现在，我还没有进入市场并在此时开始使用它，但这将会发生。加里于 2013 年去世，享年 91 岁，他直到生命的最后一刻都非常活跃。在他去世前不久，他给维基解密创始人朱利安·阿桑奇（Julian Assange）寄了一本世界政府护照，当时阿桑奇正躲在伦敦的厄瓜多尔大使馆里，还寄给了逃亡的国家安全承包商爱德华·斯诺登（Edward Snowden），
who's been living in Russia since his U.S. passport had been revoked. Gary Davis's view of political boundaries was not that they shouldn't exist, but rather that they don't exist. He said they're a legal fiction we've all come to believe in, and by placing himself outside the realm of the nation state, he'd thereby rendered them obsolete. For Gary, the idea of world government was not some far-out utopian vision, but rather an idea rooted in pragmatism. He said we're all world citizens, but it's up to each of us whether we want to recognize that fact. When I first met Gary at his home there in Vermont, he told me about a recent trip he had taken to visit his kids who lived in Montreal. Coming back, he arrived at the U.S. border, as usual, with only his world government passport. At first, immigration refused to let him pass.
自从他的美国护照被吊销后，他一直住在俄罗斯。加里·戴维斯对政治边界的看法并不是它们不应该存在，而是它们并不存在。他说，它们是我们都开始相信的法律虚构，通过将自己置于民族国家领域之外，他从而使它们过时了。对加里来说，世界政府的想法并不是什么遥远的乌托邦愿景，而是一个植根于实用主义的想法。他说我们都是世界公民，但这取决于我们每个人是否想承认这一事实。当我第一次在佛蒙特州的家中见到加里时，他告诉我他最近去探望住在蒙特利尔的孩子们的旅行。回程时，他像往常一样只拿着他的世界政府护照抵达美国边境。起初，移民局拒绝让他通过。
It was the same bureaucratic showdown he'd faced many times over the years. Gary told them that their borders were ridiculous. He said that the sun shined the same on both sides of their imaginary line and that he was just going from one part of the world to another. Eventually, they relented. Get out of here, they said, go home. When we come back, I talk with Scott about the work of Gary's world government today. Stay tuned.
这是他多年来面临的同样的官僚对峙。加里告诉他们，他们的边界太荒谬了。他说，太阳照在我们想象中的那条线的两边是一样的，他只是从世界的一个地方到另一个地方。最终，他们心软了。滚吧，他们说，回家吧。当我们回来时，我和斯科特谈谈今天加里世界政府的工作。请收听。
So I'm back with Scott Gurian, who originally produced that story for his podcast, Far From Home. Scott, welcome back to the show. Thanks so much. Thanks so much for having me, Roman. So this is all from an interview that you did with Gary nearly 20 years ago. So I wanted to get a bit of an update from you. You mentioned that the organization that Gary founded, it's still around. What is their mission today?
所以我回到了斯科特·古里安身边，他最初为他的播客《远离家乡》制作了这个故事。斯科特，欢迎回到节目中。非常感谢。非常感谢邀请我，罗曼。所以这都是来自你近 20 年前对加里的采访。所以我希望从你那里得到一些最新的情况。你提到加里创立的组织依然存在。他们今天的使命是什么？
Like, how has it changed since Gary's death? So I actually spoke to David Gallup, who's the president and general counsel of what they're now calling the world citizen government. And he says the organization has kind of broadened their focus a little bit since Gary's death. When he was around, you know, they were just kind of very insular and Gary, you know, in retrospect, was really opinionated. He could be like difficult to work with at times. He just wouldn't have patience for people who didn't exactly agree with his vision, you know, of how the world should work. So, yeah, I think in some senses, Gary's death kind of freed up the organization to kind of pursue things a little bit differently.
比如，自从加里去世后，它发生了怎样的变化？实际上，我跟大卫·加卢普交谈过，他是他们现在所说的世界公民政府的总裁兼总法律顾问。他说，自加里去世以来，该组织在某种程度上稍微拓宽了他们的关注点。当他在世的时候，你知道的，他们非常孤立，而且回顾过去，加里真的很有主见。有时他可能会很难共事。对于那些不完全同意他对世界应如何运转的愿景的人，他简直缺乏耐所以，是的，我认为在某种意义上，加里的去世在某种程度上解放了这个组织，使其能够以略微不同的方式去追求事物。
You know, nowadays, they're working with other organizations more. In specific terms, some of the things that the world citizen government is focusing on nowadays, they're working on advocating for the creation of a world court of human rights, and they're also trying to expand the movement to a younger audience. They're creating these world citizen clubs at a bunch of high schools and college campuses all over the place. Nice. Are they still making world government passes?
你知道的，现在他们更多地与其他组织合作。具体来说，世界公民政府现在关注的一些事情包括：他们致力于倡导建立一个世界人权法院，并且他们还试图将这场运动扩展到更年轻的受众群体。他们在世界各地的许多高中和大学校园里创建了这些世界公民俱乐部。太棒了。他们还在制作世界政府通行证吗？
Oh, yes, definitely. Yeah. They've now issued about a million of them, as well as a number of other identity documents. So there is still a demand and they're still fulfilling that need. And do they work? I mean, do they work without the power of Gary behind them, you know? Yeah, yeah, that's interesting question. And I touched on this a little on my piece, but they, so the world citizen government says that 189 countries have recognized the passport on a case-by-case basis. And they say there's a small number which at one point or another have given like de facto recognition. They've sent letters saying that we officially recognize this, though, in many of those cases, it's been years ago. And it's unclear whether they still do.
哦，是的，绝对是的。是的。他们现在已经发行了大约一百万份，以及其他一些身份文件。所以需求依然存在，他们也仍在满足这种需求。那它们管用吗？我的意思是，在没有加里在背后支撑力量的情况下，它们管用吗，你知道的？是的，是的，这是一个有趣的问题。我在我的报道中稍微触及了这一点，但是，世界公民政府表示，有189个国家在逐案基础上承认了这本护照。他们还说，有少数国家在某个时候给予了事实上的承认。他们曾发信表示我们正式承认这一点，尽管在许多情况下，那已经是多年前的事了。目前还不清楚他们是否仍然这样做。
The world government says the only way that they have of knowing for sure, like if their passports are working is when users of the passports send them back stamps. Well, they send photos. Oh, oh. Yeah, yeah. It really does work, believe it or not. I know it's hard to believe. But no, people send back stamps, and they said they've collected thousands of these over the years of border guards, like issued, you know, passport stamps as well as like work permits and visas, you know, in the world government passport. So these documents are honored in many cases.
世界政府表示，他们唯一能确定护照是否起作用的方法，就是当护照使用者将盖有印章的护照寄回来时。好吧，他们会寄照片。哦，哦。是的，是的。信不信由你，它真的起作用。我知道这很难相信。但是不，人们会把印章寄回来，他们说这些年里他们收集了成千上万个这样的印章，包括边防警卫签发的护照印章，以及世界政府护照内的工作许可和签证。因此，在许多情况下，这些文件是受到尊重的。
Like they told me this one case of this businessman who had been traveling all over Latin America with his world passport, he sent it into the world citizen government because he was so successful using it that he had run out of space. He needed more pages. Like, they were just really impressed. That's amazing. So who are the people who are applying for world government passports today? Is it all people like you, they're just like, oh, this would be a fun thing to have or people who really need some kind of documentation? From what I hear, it's a mix. As always, you know, there are just people who are uncomfortable with the current system who want a second form of ID, you know, like people from certain nationalities who might face hostility in certain parts of the world because of where they're from or people serving in some kind of.
就像他们向我讲述的这个案例：有一位商人一直带着他的世界护照在拉丁美洲各地旅行，他把它寄给了世界公民政府，因为他使用得太成功了，以至于护照空间都用完了。他需要更多的页数。简直让他们印象深刻。太神奇了。那么，现在都是些什么人在申请世界政府护照呢？是不是全都是像你这样的人，觉得“哦，拥有这个会很有趣”，还是说那些真正需要某种身份证明文件的人？据我所听到的，这是两者的结合。一如既往，你知道的，有一些人对现行体制感到不适，想要第二种身份证件，你知道的，比如某些国籍的人，由于他们的出身，可能会在世界的某些地方面临敌意；或者是在某种...
kind of role like working with an NGO, you know, international aid workers where they, you know, their primary identity is helping people around the world not to their individual nation state. So they want this kind of world government passport. But then, you know, there are also people who really desperately needed, who need some form of ID like refugees and stateless individuals fleeing persecution, violence or natural disasters. You know, after the war broke out between Russia and Ukraine, the world citizen government tells me they got tons of letters and emails on both sides of the conflict, people trying to escape and didn't want to be conscripted to fight in the military. They've also heard from lots of people in the Palestinian territories. And then we should mention,
某种角色中工作的人，比如与非政府组织合作的人、国际援助人员，你知道的，他们的主要身份是帮助世界各地的人，而不是效忠于他们个人的民族国家。所以他们想要这种世界政府护照。但是随后，你知道的，也有那些真正迫切需要它的人，他们需要某种形式的身份证件，比如逃离迫害、暴力或自然灾害的难民和无国籍个人。你知道的，在俄乌战争爆发后，世界公民政府告诉我，他们收到了来自冲突双方的大量信件和电子邮件，都是那些试图逃离且不想被强征入伍作战的人。他们还收到了许多巴勒斯坦领土上人们的来信。然后我们应该提到，
in addition to issuing identity documents, they also provide free legal advocacy to refugees and stateless people around the world. Oh, wow. So, you know, listening to Gary, you know, his vision of a world without nation states, it sounds pretty fanciful. And I think one of the things that also comes to mind is a one world government also sounds like maybe that might be worse. Yeah. I don't know for sure. I've never seen it. I mean, at some point, if you have a world government, you have to decide how that government functions. And do they have a concept of that? Like, is it democratic? Is it autocratic? Yeah, it was definitely democratic, they would say. But they didn't, yeah, but Gary, he himself didn't really focus on like the actual, what form the government would take and the elected representatives and how, you know, he kind of left that to others.
除了签发身份文件之外，他们还为世界各地的难民和无国籍人士提供免费的法律辩护。哦，哇。所以，你知道的，听加里讲述他关于一个没有民族国家的世界的愿景，听起来非常异想天开。而且我认为浮现在脑海的事情之一是，一个世界单一政府听起来可能也更糟糕。是的。我不敢确定。我从未见过。我的意思是，在某种程度上，如果你有一个世界政府，你就必须决定这个政府是如何运作的。他们对此有什么概念吗？比如，它是民主的吗？它是专制的吗？是的，他们会说这绝对是民主的。但他们并没有，是的，加里本人并没有真正专注于实际的、政府会采取什么形式、当选代表以及，你知道的，他某种程度上把这些留给了其他人。
Yeah, you know, he was just a provocateur. I'm just like, this is not working, we'll figure out something else. But like figuring out like how many electors are brought to do a thing. Like who wants to do that? No, they then they clearly said Gary was not a communist. He was not an anarchist. I mean, it wasn't like a political ideology behind it that like an ism, you know, that you would think of. I mean, there's this way in which the lack of specifics can be really useful. Like we're recording this in the immediate after. math of the ice surge in Minneapolis. And there's a border patrol secret police of masked people without warrants who are violently detaining and it's sometimes killing people. There's like broader waves of mass deportations in the United States and travel restrictions. And I love how Derry's attitude kind of like resets the conversation a little bit. Yeah. Like the common rhetoric is that the border is broken. You know, we have to do something to fix it. And no matter if you're like a Democrat or Republican, you still say those kind of talking points and that there's these nuances to approach these things. And I just love that there's someone standing there
是的，你知道的，他只是一个煽动者。我只是觉得，这行不通，我们会想出别的办法。但是弄清楚比如要带多少选举人来做一件事。谁想做那件事呢？不，他们随后明确表示加里不是共产主义者。他不是无政府主义者。我的意思是，它背后并没有那种你可能会想到的政治意识形态，也就是某种主义，你知道的。我的意思是，这种缺乏具体细节的方式有时真的非常有用。就像我们录制这期节目的背景，正值明尼阿波利斯移民及海关执法局突袭行动之后不久。那里有由蒙面、没有搜查令和暴力拘留甚至有时杀害平民的边境巡逻秘密警察。美国各地出现了更大规模的大规模驱逐浪潮和旅行限制。我非常喜欢德里的态度在某种程度上稍微重新调整了对话。是的。常见的辞令是边境已经崩溃了。你知道的，我们必须做点什么来修复它。不管你是民主党人还是共和党人，你仍然会说那种陈词滥调，并且处理这些事情还有各种细微差别。而我就是喜欢有人站在那里
saying a statement that I completely agree with, which is like, I could not give less of a about your documentation and immigration status as a human. Like, I can't even imagine caring about it. And I like that there's someone out there just saying that. Yeah. Yeah. It's, I mean, we're so used to having identity documents and passports that we just take them all for granted. And Gary's just totally outside of that framework, just saying we need to just get rid of this whole system and like why are you putting more value in this document that like this is a human being in front of you and you know like you're putting so way too much importance on the papers they have. I love that he's asking the question. Yeah. I think the other point I'll make is that,
发表一个我完全赞同的声明，那就是：作为一个人类，我对你的文件和移民身份真是一点都不在乎。我的意思是，我甚至无法想象去在意它。我喜欢有这样一个人就在那里直言不讳。是的。是的。这是，我的意思是，我们太习惯于拥有身份文件和护照了，以至于把它们全都视为理所当然。而加里完全跳出了这个框架，只是说我们需要彻底摆脱整个体系，为什么你要赋予这份文件比你面前活生生的人更多的价值，你知道的，你把那些纸张看得太重要了。我喜欢他提出这个问题。是的。我想我要提出的另一点是，
you know, as Americans, we've historically been pretty spoiled when it comes to travel. I mean, there's, I think, close to 200 countries in the world and our American passports allow us to go to a large portion of those without having to get a visa ahead of time. Yeah, yeah. I mean, we've had the privilege of having our own world passport most of the time. Yeah. Like effectively, like we can travel the world, just that other people cannot. Yeah, yeah. But President Trump recently signed this ban for dozens of countries seeking to visit the United States. And so in response, some of those nations have actually started making it more difficult for Americans to visit. And several countries in Africa now completely prohibit ordinary Americans from visiting.
你知道的，作为美国人，在旅行方面，我们历来都被宠坏了。我的意思是，我认为世界上将近有200个国家，而我们的美国护照让我们无需提前办理签证就可以去其中的很大一部分国家。是的，是的。我的意思是，大多数时候我们都享有拥有我们自己的世界护照的特权。是的。就像实际上，我们可以周游世界，而其他人却不能。是的，是的。但特朗普总统最近签署了一项针对数十个寻求访问美国的国家的旅行禁令。因此作为回应，其中一些国家实际上开始让美国人更难前往访问。非洲的好几个国家现在完全禁止普通美国人访问。
Yeah. And I think Americans are kind of getting a taste of what it's been like for people in the rest of the world. And I guess you could say that Gary's notions of being world citizens are, you know, more important now than ever. So I have one final most important question. Do you still have your world passport? I do. Have you ever tried to use it?
是的。而且我认为美国人正在某种程度上体验世界其他地方的人一直以来的感受。我想你可以说加里关于世界公民的概念，你知道的，现在比以往任何时候都更加重要。所以我有最后一个最重要的问题。你还留着你的世界护照吗？我有。你有没有试着用过它？
Yeah, yeah. It's expired now. I haven't gotten a new one, but this is my world. Oh, yeah. It looks like a passport. I mean, this was issued a number of years ago, so it looks a little hokey. This is the way they used to do where it's actually written in calligraphy and everything with a photo stamped in here.
是的，是的。它现在已经过期了。我没有办一本新的，但这就是我的世界。哦，是的。它看起来像一本护照。我的意思是，这是多年前签发的，所以看起来有点老土。这是他们过去的做法，实际上是用书法手写的全部内容，并盖有一张照片。
They tell me that the newer ones, they assure me, are much more professional looking, where everything is printed on the plastic, you know, and they have scannable RFID chips and everything. And the passport actually came with a little booklet of the UN Declaration of Human Rights because, as Gary would say, the passport by itself is, meaningless. It's like a hammer. You need to know how to use it. So you just can't take the passport. You bring this with you to make all the right arguments to the border guards. So hopefully they'll accept it. That's awesome. Well, Scott, it was such a fun story. It was such fun talking to you.
他们告诉我，向我保证，较新的版本看起来要专业得多，所有内容都是打印在塑料上的，你知道的，它们有可扫描的射频识别芯片和各种东西。这本护照实际上还附带了一本小册子，里面是《联合国世界人权宣言》，因为正如加里会说的那样，护照本身是毫无意义的。它就像一把锤子。你需要知道如何使用它。所以你不能只拿着护照。你得带着这个去和边防警卫进行所有正确的辩论。希望他们会接受它。太棒了。好的，斯科特，这是一个非常有趣的故事。跟你聊天太愉快了。
I really appreciate it. Thank you so much, Roman. I appreciate it as well. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Scott Gurian for his podcast, Far From Home. Other versions of this story also appeared on the program's B-Side Radio and Backstory radio with additional editing respectively by Tamara Keith and Jess Enga Bretson. Our version was edited by Joe Rosenberg, remixed by Martin Gonzalez, intro and outro music by Swan Rio. If you found Gary Davis's story interesting, we'll have a link to the far-from-home website where Scott has provided show notes, including videos of Gary, more information about the
我真的很感激。非常感谢你，罗曼。我也很感激。本周的《99%无形》由斯科特·古里安为他的播客《远离家园》进行报道。这个故事的其他版本也曾出现在该节目的 B-Side Radio 和 Backstory radio 上，分别由塔玛拉·基斯和杰斯·英加·布雷特森进行剪辑。我们的版本由乔·罗森伯格剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯重新混音，片头和片尾音乐由天鹅里约创作。如果你觉得加里·戴维斯的故事很有趣，我们将在远离家园的网站上提供一个链接，斯科特在那里提供了节目笔记，包括加里的视频、关于更多信息
world government, as well as many other stories from around the world. Honestly, it's hard to think of anyone who has put the power of the American passport to more use than Scott, so go check it out. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lasha Madon, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleeson, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
世界政府以及来自世界各地的许多其他故事。老实说，很难想到有谁比斯科特更好地利用了美国护照的力量，所以去看看吧。凯茜2号是我们的执行制作人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝伊、杰森·德莱昂、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉沙·马顿、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·麦地那·格利森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在向北六个街区、位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的潘多拉大厦。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的全新 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有一个指向该链接的通道以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。